goodbye my son
our hopes and dreams travel with you
he'll be an outcast
i'll kill him
how
he'll be a god to them
what if a child dreamed of becoming
something other than what society had
intended
what if a child aspired to something
greater
my son was in the bus
he saw what clark did
you're the answer son
you're the answer to are we alone in the
universe
can i just keep pretending i'm your son
you are my son
i have to believe that you were sent
here for a reason
and even if it takes the rest of your
life
you owe it to yourself to find out what
that reason is
how do you find someone who has spent a
lifetime covering his tracks
for some he was a guardian angel
for others a ghost who never quite fit
in
you will give the people of earth an
ideal to strive towards
they'll race behind you
they will stumble
they will fall
but in time
they will join you in the sun
in time
you will help them
accomplish wonders
you believe your son is safe
i will find him
my father believed if the world found
out who i really was
he'd reject me
he was convinced that the world wasn't
ready
what do you think
what's the s stand for
it's not an s
on my world it means hope
well here is
an s
how about
c
excuse me
you